was ich will
bucher das war nicht meine typische
begrüßung auf jeden fall schon im titel
ein gerade meine damen und herren 2014
kontrakte ja wir machen heute waren die
2004 trennte hochgeladen habe wir
starten einfach mal mit der fatah die
nato hier untersuchen jetzt mal mich
dort zu finden ist seine figur
männlichen ja wohl deine von deutschland
ja die minecraft viele ja ich würde
heute nur noch wacklig macht eine firma
menschen auf frieden mit nein spielt
eine figur mac os x war hier mit ja
heißt der kanal deiner figur kaum kräfte
ok ich hab' akinator mehrere monate
nicht hochgeladen frage 6 er kennt mich
ich klicke einfach mal auf ja warum
kennst du mir jetzt eine figur ambrosia
wird fortgesetzt am brucia ich mach mal
ich weiß es nicht und setzten von
schlachter heyo kollege david auch noch
du okay alles gleich mehrfach geklärt
ich klicke einfach mal auf ja und wir
sehen schon konkreter wurde 840.000 mal
gespielt freunde mir müssten die million
mal voll machen und als nette würde ich
sagen schauen wir beim akinator einfach
mal nach ukulele alles klar scheint
irgendwie nicht zu jucken ja meine figur
gehört kohlekraft keine flasche hat
deine figur lange goldene tal mit
magischen kräfte mal sagen nein
besteht ein video kommt ja eigentlich
nur ein amg also nicht dass ich wüsste
nein und das ist okay was schauen wir ob
kollege gespielt wurde die wurde
mittlerweile auch so nah als nächste
suchen werd mal nicht was irgendwie mit
meinen videos mit 100 sondern wir suchen
das bürgerliche gesetzbuch deutschland
das lag hier gerade noch von der klausur
das buch wurde nicht durch youtube
bekannt meine mein buch spricht
eigentlich gar keine sprache meine kino
lebt nicht wirklich meine figur läuft
nicht auf zwei beinen meine figur ist
nicht weiblich meine figur hat einen
namen ja meine figuren nicht bei augen
wir schauen nicht auf dem internet und
die keine maschine die definitiv kleiner
ich habe keine schwester wohnen nicht in
der schweiz hat nichts mit sex zu tun
wir wohnen nicht im gleichen haus kein
sponsor kostüm die kein haustier wie er
spielt mit baywatch mit ist kein tier
nicht größer als 1 meter 70 durch das
internet bekanntgeworden wird keine
übernatürlichen kräfte nicht böse wie
hatte ich nicht den booten ändern lassen
wir schwarzen der ball aus jay die
bürgerliche gesetzbuch das wasser
allerdings auch schon von der ersten
sachen die wir in den heutigen video
machen wollen und beharrt video nicht
2014 akinator da kaum kraft akinator von
2004 ein konkreteres wegen gehört dazu
natürlich auch noch der clever bot
clever bought the cloud ist eigentlich
ein lieber kerl aber wir können den
fragen stellen und der versucht eine
antwort zu finden eine lange nicht
gesehen sag ich mal im mittelkreis
doch bloß durch doch auch genauso sehe
ich das auch lieber snowboard wir wollen
ja immer lieb sein mag noch einmal die
hand aber schon okay dann nicht wie
lange haben wir uns jetzt eigentlich
nicht gewesen ist er auch eine sache die
ich mich frage der baum verfolgt mich am
boden
ja da kennst mich freunde frage wie
lange sie nicht gewinnt hat man denkt da
kommt eine antwort von wegen ein paar
monate nicht schön dich wiederzusehen
aber nein er war der baum verfolgt mich
am boden
jetzt weiß ich warum ich das nicht mehr
hochgeladen habe willst du mich
eigentlich komplett verarschen lieber
clever bot das kann doch nicht wahr sein
dass mir so eine scheiße antwort gibt
wieso sollte ich das tun weil du mir
richtig antwortet die antwort darauf ist
ich kann schon rechnen aber ich bin im
gym und ich kann noch nicht so gut
englisch
der körper baut kann schon gerechnet
aber der ist im gym deswegen noch nicht
so gut englisch wie bist du denn gerade
im gym weil da fragt man sich natürlich
dass mein körper wird ist natürlich eine
maschine was hat er denn im sind
besuchen bin ich doch gar alles klar
wahrscheinlich hat gerade nicht du bist
im gym geschrieben das hast du da aber
gerade mitgeteilt lieber clever bord
natürlich immer nett bleiben freunde
wird bescheid freundlichkeit kommt am
leben nein habe ich nicht
nein habe ich nicht habe gesagt ich ein
mädchen bin
warum bin ich ein hocker thomas egger
aber darauf antwortet doch hast du
willst du den screenshot
das kunstgrün schattiger was für einen
screenshot denn jetzt fragezeichen ich
dachte ich bin bin ein hock was ist denn
jetzt los lieber keller war ich versteh
gar nicht was gerade gewählt weil du
mich noch heiraten
heiraten wieso will ich heiraten pumpen
erklären aber bist du ein junge ja ich
bin ein junge mit doppel die hatte dass
er geschrieben
ist dir eigentlich klar dass wir nur mit
anderen menschen schreiben und unser
schreibt pater nach ein paar sekunden
wieder wechseln
[Musik]
clever wort ja mir ist das klar
das mussten jetzt nämlich erklärt der
plattform will pizza pizza die parteien
ja drei auto bezeichnen ich darf
eigentlich nicht mit dir schreiben warum
nicht warum darf ich mit beschreiben die
backwaters caroline link sein weil du
kein leben
hö
was geht so ab gerade bei dir würde mich
auch mal interessieren weil wir unser
land gewesen das hat sich schon einmal
gefragt ja und ich frage dich ein
weiteres mal punkt punkt punkt weil es
mir nicht beantworten weil ich drin bin
dir doch einfach eine antwort darauf
sagt er nein ich bin ein junge wie oft
muss ich dir das noch erklären so dumme
part 4 kind hat vier kinder eltern leben
vom kindergeld bei dir oder dein clown
da muss ich jetzt wirklich an der stelle
anmerken lieber körperbau zu erschweren
kann ich mich normalerweise eher weniger
die dritte waffe die wir heute spielen
werden 2014 crafter video ist gott ihm
entschuldigen geht habe ich auch schon
lange nicht mehr hochgeladen und wir
sehen schon dass uns eine ziege die
gerade glaube ich gestorben weil sie gar
nicht mehr kennt das spiel wo wir die
wir auch im garten fahrrad wenn sie den
später wtf alter das paar hat mich
irgendwohin geschleudert wo bin ich denn
jetzt auf jeden fall ein spiel wo man
sie gehört und man kann herumlaufen den
gescheit machen und irgendwie bin ich
außerhalb von der mep jetzt gerade was
die linke ist der map brand eigentlich
wollte ich nur so ein bisschen die welt
ein bisschen zu schauen was man machen
kann aber irgendwie komme ich auch gar
nicht wieder in die welt rein also hier
bin ich jetzt noch irgend einem berg und
bin jetzt bin ich wieder in der welt ich
wollte eigentlich nur das fahrrad
schnappen und ein bisschen radeln das
ganze nicht so funktioniert auf jeden
fall können wir an dieser welt hier gar
nicht herumlaufen da oben ist ein
paraglider der fliegt gerade keine
ahnung wohin fliegt man kann die zeit
machen wie beispielsweise hier so
autogrammen dann kriegt man woanders hin
kann er hier stehen und hier wieder ein
auto rahmen rahmen und jetzt liege ich
auf einem dach ich habe sogar mal ein
video gemacht wo ich glaube ich jeder
einzelne statue gefunden weiß ich habe
eh schon irgendwie ziehen könnt nicht
gott simulator videos gemacht wo ich das
spiel mehr oder weniger komplett
durchgespielt habe und trotzdem noch
kommentare hey you got you later hoch
und ich denke also was soll ich denn
noch machen als wenn ich eine idee habe
ich eindeutig da noch machen kann
deswegen welche anderen web gibt ich
meine ich ja auch schon die payback und
alle anderen maps habe ich eh schon
gespielt die auch am strand und so was
alles wenn irgendwelche ideen hat dann
sagt gerne mal bescheid was tue ich hier
eigentlich gerade die kriegen was drauf
ich weiß nicht genau was ich glaube aber
das ist für die
alles klar
der flop all in ging
das ist genauso wie wir nicht im chip
bin weiß ich was ich jetzt genau machen
soll
ich hatte halt nur diese motivation mit
laden war ich doch da habe ich bei bhp
einmal vor ein zwei jahren gesehen habe
lässt sich auch vom content her ein
bisschen entwickelt und hat ein video
gemacht sachen gemacht hat die er früher
sehr häufig gemacht hat auf jeden fall
wollte jetzt auch mal die sachen
hochladen die ich früher zeit hochladen
habe akinator clever wort und gott ihm
aber dann hab ich im games der nahezu
mehr oder weniger durchgeführt was ich
schon immer noch ausprobieren wollte war
ob man so ein lkw oder von autovaz
hierher fährt irgendwie rahmen kann also
ich glaube da hinten
dahinter kommt keine karte hier vorne
kommt auch gerade kein auto also ob ich
jetzt quasi auf merkur ankara den waffen
manche tatsächlich nur gefahren also
anderen autos die hier stehen kann man
ja einfach hingehen und kann sagen was
und jetzt sitzt quasi die ganze
tankstelle weg ja geil steckte schönen
avant her frauen die dort wohin standard
wenn ich jetzt durch die wand
jetzt hängt ihr fuß weiter reihen sind
jetzt auf dach ich glaube wirklich dass
ich alles in diesem verdammten spiel
schon mal irgendwie gemacht habe ich
werde hier oben her laufen und schauen
was ich hier noch befindet aber ein mann
also nicht gut laufen jetzt erstmal eine
kleine runde gab wie ich würde sagen
freunde
in diesem spiel kann ich jetzt einen
etat allzu viel machen also ich habe
alles mögliche kaputt gemacht ich aber
schon alle tief mit eingesammelt und was
gold simi liter etwas mittlerweile auch
jeder darf ich das heutige video dieser
stelle auch beenden mir hat mal wieder
sehr viel spaß gemacht
warum zu machen die ich früher auf
meinem kanal hochgeladen habe erstmal
leica freunde wenn ich demnächst auch
mal irgendwie einfach aus minecraft
wieder spielen soll oder so also ein
bisschen wechselberg kontrakt am tisch
vor ein paar jahren ihr wisst bescheid
freunde mit leben und jetzt will ich
sagen meine damen und herren der moment
kommen auf den alle gewartet haben
das
a
ihr könnt jetzt hier meinen kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
stecken ihr findet jetzt für andere
videos und berlin und abonnent
vielleicht wird ihr auch die glocken
fliegen dann wir kommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]